There always seems to be a little bit of a narrative of destruction
around decentralized weapons.
And I really see it as something quite positive,
as a beautiful opportunity for people to feel empowered.
The founder of pro-gun group has been posting instructions online for using 3D printers-
The federal government settled the lawsuit with Wilson's organization Defense Distributed.
more than 2,500 people have downloaded Cody Wilson's blueprints
for 3D printed AR-15 assault style rifles.
Coming to a school near you.
These ghost guns are the new wave of American gun violence.
We're here to expressly outlaw so-called ghost guns.
The man at the center of the debate over 3D printed guns
has been charged with sexually assaulting a child.
My name is Paloma Heindorff, I'm the new director of Defense Distributed.
Defense Distributed, the Austin Texas-based company
best known for introducing to the world a 3D printed gun called The Liberator,
has had a wild seven months.
It reached a settlement in a long-standing federal lawsuit,
Reposted all of its downloadable gun files on the internet,
was sued by 25 states and then had to pull all those files back down.
Yet the most consequential event for the company
was the arrest and indictment of its founder Cody Wilson on a sex crime charge.
Stepping up as the new director was Paloma Heindorff
who had almost no experience on the public stage
and hadn't even fired a gun prior to 2015.